>> Suzanne Schadl: My
name is Suzanne Schadl,
I am the new chief in the
Hispanic division here
in the Library of Congress.
I'd like to welcome the audience
and thank you for coming.
I would like to say just
real quickly a few words
about the Hispanic division and
about Talia Guzman-Ganzalez,
who has organized today's event.
So, does everybody here know
about the Hispanic division
and what we do for
the most part?
So, I'll just reiterate.
I think one of the most
-- this is from me --
important things that we do is
that we provide people who
help people and you can see
when we're talking
about corrections
that we have corrections
in many different parts
of the Library of Congress.
So, here today you
have rare books,
you have general collection,
you have prints and photographs.
And they all deal with
some extent with the topic
of our presentation today
and that's brought together
by Talia, who has also
brought in community members
and academics who are
experts in this field.
So, one of the most important
contributions we can make is
to bring resources and
people and discussions
about those resources
and topics together.
And I'm very grateful to
Talia and many others of you
in the room to do that kind of
work, so I'm going to turn it
over to her so she can
introduce our speaker.
And thank you.
>> TALIA GUZMAN-GONZALEZ:
Thank you, Suzanne.
Welcome, everyone to this event.
On behalf of my colleagues
in Hispanic division,
I would like to welcome you
all to the Library of Congress.
And especially to these
book talk, State of Grace,
Utopia in Brazilian
Culture, by Patricia Vieira
and it would be moderated
by Professor Thayse Lina.
I'm going to introduce
our speakers,
then Professor Vieira will come
here and do a short presentation
of the book and then we'll move
to the moderate conversation
with Professor Lina.
There's going to be time for
questions, so, please, you know,
if something comes up, feel
free to ask at the end,
and hopefully you'll also take
advantage of seeing the --
some of the wonderful books
that we have here today.
Patricia Vieira is a
social professor of Spanish
and Portuguese at
Georgetown University.
And Associate research professor
at the Center for Social Studies
of the University
of [inaudible].
Her fields of expertise
are comparative literature,
literature and philosophy,
literary theory, utopian studies
and environmental studies.
She is the author of,
Seeing Politics Otherwise,
Vision in Latin American
and Iberian Fiction.
Portuguese Film, 1930 to 1960.
The Staging of the New State
Regime and States of Grace,
Utopia in Brazilian Culture and
the coeditor of several books,
including, Existential
Utopia, New Prospects
of Utopian Thought, the Language
of Plants, Science, Philosophy,
Literature and the Green Thread,
Dialogues with the
Vegetable World.
She is published numerous
academic articles in her field
of expertise, as well as op
ads in the New York times,
the LA Review of Books and
the European, among others.
This conversation, like
I said, will be moderated
by Professor Thayse Lina,
who teaches in the department
of Spanish and Portuguese at
the University of Maryland.
Her areas of specialization
include 19tyh century
contemporary Brazilian
literature and culture,
modern Latin American literature
and intellectual history,
transnationalism
and international
literary circulation.
She's currently working
on a book project
that traces the dialogues
between Hispanic American
and Brazilian cultural
and literary critics during the
second half of the 20th century,
focusing on the efforts
to integrate the two
distinctly tried traditions
of Latin America.
I would also like to add
that Thayse has been here
several times to work
on her book and I look forward
to seeing you here next --
soon, to present that
book here as well.
Her articles and book reviews
have appeared in journals,
such as Hispania, Brazil,
Brazil, Literature America
and Portuguese Literary
and Cultural Studies.
Please join me in
welcoming Thayse
and Patricia to this
presentation.
[ Applause ]
>> Patricia Vieira: Well,
good afternoon, everyone.
I'd like to first of all
thank Dr. Talia Guzman
and the Hispanic division for
the opportunity to be here
and to talk to you a bit
about my most recent book.
And to thank Dr. Thayse Lina for
accepting to moderate the debate
and to talk a bit about
the book later on.
And I would like to
start with a few words
about the Brazilian elections.
Those of you who are even
a bit interested in Brazil,
probably have followed
the elections
that took place this last Sunday
and I think in the context
of those elections it becomes
more important than ever
to reflect upon utopia
and the two candidates
who will face each other in the
second round of the elections
at the end of the mouth.
Jair Balsonaro and Fernando
Haddad, they both, of course,
presents two almost
diametrically opposed views
of Brazil.
One a very nationalistic
and tradition
and even authoritarian
vision of the country
and the other one
the dream of a kind
of a more egalitarian Brazil
that would be more open
to external influences.
That I would argue that both
candidates go back to some
of the utopian themes that have
shaped the history of Brazil
and Brazilian thought
throughout the centuries.
And just as an example,
Balsonaro draws heavily
on the messianic tradition
that I discuss in the book.
I don't know if all of you know,
but his middle name is actually
the Portuguese for Messiah,
[inaudible], and he often
presents himself as this savior
who is going to come and lead
the country to a golden age
of security and of stability,
even if this comes at the cost
of embracing past racial
and gender hierarchies.
And, of course, of cementing
some of the economic disparities
that have plagued Brazil.
Haddad's platform on the other
hand goes back to the promise
of social political and economic
justice that has been one
of the key tenants of
one Brazilian utopianism
as I discussed in the book.
And, so, even though they
are both very different,
both of these candidates go
back to utopian ideas of Brazil
that I think we need to
really analyze in order
to understand what is going
on today in the country.
So, the idea to write this
book, I rose precisely
from this reflection that Brazil
has throughout the centuries
been a repository for
Utopian aspirations.
And so that was the goal of
my project, to kind of go back
to these utopian aspirations
that have shaped
what Brazil is today.
An Example of this is
Thomas More's book, Utopia,
and you have the copy of I
believe the first edition
of Thomas More's
Utopia, from 1516.
And in this book and in Thomas
More's utopia, of course,
the word utopia was coined,
right and in this book
Thomas More, British writer,
he imagines an island
that would be more perfect
than the England of his kind.
And use of this island
supposedly was brought
to Thomas More by a Portuguese
sailor called Raphael.
And you can see here
he's alluding
to the Portuguese voyages to
Africa, to Asia, and especially
to the Americas, right?
this is a map, of
course, fictional map
of the fictional island
of utopia from the end
of the 16th century based
on Thomas More's book.
So, More he never really
specified the coordinates
of his imaginary
island of Utopia.
But he did write that
it was located somewhere
in the New World.
And given that I was first
visited by a Portuguese sailor,
we can imagine that maybe More
had the land that is now Brazil
in mind when he wrote about
this island of Utopia, right.
The Utopian drive became
part of Brazil's cultural
and intellectual
DNA from the arrival
from the first Portuguese
sailors and settlers onwards.
The regions environment was
often compared to paradise,
because it was so
lush and bountiful.
And even Brazil's pre-Columbian
inhabitants were first regarded
as very amicable and friendly.
Of course, this then this
perception then changed
as colonization progressed.
But early Brazil was seen
by European explorers
as utopia realized.
This is a painting called,
The First Mass in Brazil,
by a painter from
the romantic period.
I think it's from
1861, this painting,
and the painter is
Victor Meirelles.
And you can see here some of
the things I'm talking about.
So, the lush environment,
the large trees.
You have, of course,
the religious element,
you have the soldiers
also there.
And then you have
in the foreground the
native Brazilian population,
which looks on, they
look on with interest
and without any sort
of animosity
at the colonizers, right?
One of the most powerful
utopian forces
that really led settlers --
well, that led settlers to
establish themselves in Brazil
in the beginning was, of course,
an economic reason, right?
Brazil at first there
was lots of money made
through the selling of sugar
produced in Brazil in Europe,
so the cane plantations were
the first large scale economic
practice in Brazil.
Then there was the gold rush in
Brazil, which was another seen
as an easy path to
enrichment, right, so, again,
this utopian idea that if you go
to Brazil you'll
get money easily
and you'll get rich easily.
This is a picture from the 1980s
by Brazilian photographer,
Sebastiao Salgado.
And, so mining continues
to be an important activity
in Brazil to this day.
This is in [inaudible], which is
in the southern part of Prada,
so in the northern
area of Brazil.
And then another moment
where there was this idea
of easy enrichment in Brazil
with the so called Rubber Boom
in the Amazon in the late
19th, early 20th century,
where the sale of
latex in Europe,
because rubber was
needed to produce,
among other things,
tires for cars.
So, people extracted latex from
the rubber trees in the Amazon
and that created
prodigious wealth
in the Amazon reason, right?
So, my point is that
various moments
in its history Brazil was
seen of a kind of El Dorado,
where you could just go
and get rich very easily
without too much work.
But, these economic
considerations I think do not
exhaust the utopian
aura of Brazil.
The idea that Brazil is an
economic El Dorado goes hand
in hand with the idea that also
social politically Brazil can
point the way to the future.
There is an Austrian
author called Stefan Zweig,
who titled his book from
the 1940s, Precisely Brazil,
a Country of the Future.
And in this book, which
we also have therefore you
to see afterwards, he contrasts
the racism that was prevalent
in Europe at the time he was
writing during the Second
World War.
And so he contrasts
the situation in Europe
that was engulfed in racial
bigotry with the situation
in Brazil that he sees as the
prototype for human relations
in the rest of the globe.
Of course, he might have
a somewhat rosy picture
of what Brazil was, but he
believed that the country
and this is a quote from his
book, "Is destined to become one
of the most important factors
in the future development
of our world."
And he continues by
writing about Brazil,
"I knew that I had glimpsed
the future of our world."
And he says, "Brazil gave me the
feeling of living in a process
of becoming, in what is
to come, in the future."
And, so, this idea of Brazil as
being a country of the future
that points the way to how our
future might look like remains
to this day and I think
became very much a part
of the country's identity.
To this day Brazilian
politicians, economists,
scholars and so on, speculate
about whether the country
will be able to live
up to its promise of being a
country of the future enough
and this is very much at play
also in the electoral race
in the rhetoric of
both candidates.
So, In States of Grace, in this
book that I have just published,
I traced how this idea of Brazil
as a utopian land was reworked
by Brazilian intellectuals
at various moments
in the country's history.
And my first step was where
the messianic writings
of Jesuit priest, Antonio
Vieira, whom you can see here,
are preaching to Brazilian
Indians, pointing, of course,
to heaven, right, which is --
it's very interesting that,
of course, the indigenous
population is seen as close
to the ground and they have
to somehow rise up spiritually
in the direction
of heaven, right?
So, this was my first step in
the book and the utopian moment
in his writings is that he
believes that the colonization
of Brazil was the first
-- not the colonization,
the colonization and
the evangelization
or the Christianization
of Brazil was going
to be the first step
of Christianization
of the entire world.
And this conversion
of the entire world
to Catholicism would herald
the second coming of Christ,
who would establish
a millenarian kingdom
of peace on Earth.
So, you can see the utopian
undertones of his thought here.
Another moment I explored in
the book was the perception
of the Amazon and you have
here a beautiful image
of the Amazon during
the time of the flood
when the river is
very full, right?
So, the Amazon has also been
perceived as a utopian space,
both by Brazilians and by
foreign explorers who project
onto the Amazon their ideas of
social and political justice.
I also discussed in the
book the close relationship
between Brazilian culture
and the environment
as a source of utopianism.
Brazil, as you all know,
is rightly so associated
to biodiversity and Brazilian
writers have often imagined
alternative relationships
to animals and plants
that would not be predicated
on just exploitation.
And then a final
topic I discussed
in the book was the
conception of Brazil
as a society of leisure.
And while colonizers often
criticized the work ethics
of native Brazilians, Brazilian
intellectuals have come
to imagine leisure
and even laziness
as a positive Brazilian trait
that distinguishes Brazil
from other countries in
Europe and in North America.
And according to this view of
Brazil, the country's laziness
or leisurely way of life,
heralds a future time
when machines will do all
the work and we will be able
to devote ourselves to
leisurely pursuits, such as,
for instance, artistic pursuits.
Right? This is a clip from a
1969 film titled Macunaima,
by Joaquim Pedro de
Andrade, and Macunaima,
who is said to be the hero of
Brazil, the hero of our people,
as it is said in the book, he
was defined by his laziness,
he was extremely lazy,
didn't like to work at all.
And here you see him
lying in a hammock
where he spends a lot of time.
And the film is in and of itself
a rework of a novel published
in 1928 by Mario de
Adnrade, modernist writer.
Also called Macunaima.
And also in the novel
Macunaima is extremely lazy
and has his brothers
do most of the work.
And this is again seen
as something positive,
so it's not criticized
in the book.
It's seen as a positive
trait and it's almost
as if Brazilian intellectuals
were embracing a criticism
that is also often leveled
against Brazilians, right,
that Brazilians are lazy, they
don't like doing too much work.
And, so, these intellectuals
were saying, yes,
but this is a good thing
that we resist doing work
that in fact leads nowhere.
Right, so, this is another
moment of utopianism
that I explored in the book.
So, positing Brazil as
this country of the future,
as some of these utopias
do, creates a kind of a gap
between Brazil's present
reality as a country
that has a certain
set of limitations
and the utopian expectations
that we place up on Brazil.
And this so called, we could
call it even a cognizant
dissonance between reality as
it is and reality as we would
like it to be creates a problem
that Brazilians respond to,
I would think, in
two different ways.
On the one hand the
significance of utopia
for Brazilian identity
contributes
to what has been called
oofanista [phonetic
spelling] attitude.
Oofanista means just proud
or self-congratulatory.
And, so, often in -- if
you espouse this attitude,
you tend to disregard Brazil's
problems and to believe
that Brazil is the
greatest nation on Earth,
surpassing even the wildest
utopian expectations.
This is the main
argument of a book titled,
Why I Am Proud of My Country.
In Portuguese, [speaking foreign
language], published in 1900.
And in this book
by Alfonso Selsu,
the author really just
lavishes praise on Brazil
as the greatest country
on Earth and it says
if Brazil is really
utopia realized.
And this mindset has
resurfaced at several moments
in Brazil's cultural history.
For instance, during the
period of modernismo,
which I already modernism,
which I already talked about.
Some of the factions that
emerged during this period,
they really had a radically
nationalistic oofanista agenda
that advocated the
superiority of Brazilian values
and of the Brazilian way
of being in the world.
This segment of modernism
was associated
with far right political
movements, such as integralism
and this is a picture
of Brazilian integralists
demonstrating.
And then some of these values
of integralism then fed
into the nationalism
of [inaudible] totalitarian
new states
in the late 1930s and 1940s.
And, again, the military
dictatorship that ruled Brazil
between '64 and '85 went back
to some of the oofanista values,
singing the glory of
the Brazilian nation.
And I would argue to a certain
extent current candidate
for Brazilian presidency,
[inaudible] also goes back
to some of these ideas
of oofanismal [phonetic
spelling] praising a certain
version of what Brazil
is as opposed to --
as opposed to a more,
let's say, horizontal view
of what the country could be.
So, I'm not saying that
nationalism and allegiance
to one's country is
necessarily something negative,
but this excessively
nationalistic oofanista attitude
often entails a racist posture
and it's ultranationalism
and it's exaltation of
Brazilianess often goes hand
and hand with the --
at the debasement of other
nations and cultures.
And even with certain groups
within the Brazilian nations,
such as afro Brazilians.
All right.
So, this is one of the paths
that utopia can follow
in Brazil.
So, this cognitive dissonance
between the way things are
and the way things could be
can lead to this overtly --
over nationalistic attitude.
The other attitude it can
produce, this disparity
between how things are
and how we would like them
to be is an excessively critical
and even fatalistic view
of Brazil, according to which
Brazil permanently falls short
of one's expectations, right?
at the very mundane level
in Brazil and those of you
who know a bit about Brazil,
remember that Brazilians keep
referring to the exterior,
to the countries
that are outside
as if they were much
better than Brazil.
And, so, Brazil always
compares negatively
to other countries, right?
And the root of this
self-debasement lies
in an interpretation of
Brazil as plagued by a kind
of fundamental deficiency,
and this deficiency
has been identified
by different intellectuals
differently.
It can be racism, it can
be the profound inequality
that plagues the country, it
can be corruption, for instance,
I have a cartoon that says,
"Either Brazil finishes
corrupt people
or corrupt people
will finish Brazil."
And, so, you have all of
the corrupt people eating,
eating away at Brazil.
And again, corruption was a key
issue in this Sunday's election
and will be a key issue in the
second round as well, right?
So, [inaudible] is justified,
of course, in identifying --
in identifying the
shortcomings of Brazil
or of any other country.
Many of these shortcomings that
Brazilian intellectuals identify
as a shortcoming
of their country,
they're not problems
of Brazil alone.
I mean, they exist in most
countries in the world.
And, so, I would argue that they
do not warrant this permanent
feeling of inadequacy
of Brazil when compared
to its utopian potential.
Nor do they condemn Brazil
to somehow lag behind
and not be a better
version of itself, right?
And as we know this critical
impulse was part of utopia
from the beginning, that's why
Thomas More wrote his book,
Utopia, was to criticize
the England of his time
and to show how it could
be a better country.
So, to conclude and then I would
like to hear a bit from you,
but to conclude, In States
of Grace I tried to showed
that utopia determines Brazilian
history from the beginning
and it is and will probably
remain a central element
in Brazil's collective identity.
And, as I was discussing
just now, the very nature
of utopia is to create
this gap between what is
and what could be,
between reality
and a better version of reality.
And Brazilian intellectuals
have responded to this tension
that is part of utopianism
by hovering
between the two extremes
of exalted nationalism
and excessive criticism
of their country.
And I think that by giving in
to either of these tendencies,
Brazil risk is never
really embracing the present
and never really fulfilling
its utopian potential.
I think these two tendencies,
this excessive nationalism
and this fatalistic criticism
are easy responses to utopianism
that fail to meet the
challenge of utopia.
Because in one way or the
other they end up subscribing
to the current state of affairs.
Either because it's
already great
or because it cannot be changed.
Right? So, both of
these tendencies lead us
to stay the way we are,
so they do not prompt us
to change anything.
So, I think that Brazil
should reject these two paths
of excessive nationalism or
excessive criticism and continue
to be open to the utopian
possibilities that are woven
into the very fabric of
the nation's culture.
As Brazilians prepare to vote
in the second round of elections
in the end of October, I hope
that they will steer clear
of both this over
nationalistic attitudes and also
of a defeatist stance that only
foregrounds the negative aspects
in Brazilian culture.
The ultra conservative
rights represented
by Jai Balsonaro I
think has been able
to capitalize very well both
on the extreme nationalist
oofanista sentiment
and on a defeatist outlook of
an elector that is really tired
of corruption scandals
and the social violence.
So, Balsonaro has been, I think,
very savvy in capitalizing
on both of these attitudes.
He, of course, always presents
himself with a background
of the Brazilian
national flag or dressed
in the Brazilian
national colors.
Again, in line with
what I was talking
about this overtly
nationalistic posture.
It remains to be seen
whether the left,
represented by Fernando Haddad,
can mobilize another
more constructive version
of Brazilian utopianism,
one that would be predicated
on social and economic justice
and on environmental harmony
as a path for Brazil to live
up to its utopian promise.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thayse Lina: Hello, everyone.
Good afternoon.
Thank you very much for
the Library and Talia
and also Patrice here for
inviting me to discuss the book.
Personally it's been a
pleasure to read the book,
because I've been wrapped
around writing my own book,
so it's good to read somebody
else's thoughts and ideas.
On the other hand, on the
current context in Brazil,
which is to say the least is
scary, it was also refreshing
to have contact with some --
with a book that is
discussing something positive
for a change, which is utopia.
Even though we know that --
and I think that's what
for [inaudible] perspective
is also very interesting
from your book, is
that you refrain
from discussing negative
utopias and you also disagree
with the idea that utopians
will necessarily lead
into totalitarian systems.
So, that has been
refreshing as well,
because I think very
often we read books
that take a different
position, which are necessary
and important to take a
critical position in relation
to certain projects, right,
certain national projects
in some ways you
imagine the country.
But I think that the other
way around has been discussed
and done to exhaustion, so I
found the book very original
and very refreshing to read.
So, I'm very glad I
was invited for this.
So, I think we were going to
start with couple of questions,
then I'm going to open
for everybody else.
One of the things that I found
really interesting and new
to the book that I was
talking to you before earlier
on today was that even
though some of the projects
that you discuss are known
and some are discussed,
they were never organized
around the idea of utopia,
which I found -- it was almost
this obvious thing that was
in front of, that this is
permeating Brazilian history,
Brazilian intellectual
history, but was never discussed
as such organized as such and
I found it very interesting.
So, as you were explaining
to everybody there's a lot
of utopian streaks that run
through Brazilian history
and some of them are
related to nature,
some of them are political,
some of them are cultural,
there are messianic ones,
and that is something
that it found quite new.
I never really thought about
our intellectual history
through this lenses.
So, I -- one of the questions
that I have for you is that,
how you went about
organizing, it's such a long --
it's such a large theme and it
runs through such a, you know,
basically the whole
history of Brazil.
Everything, the discoveries.
How did you go about selecting
what you were going to have
in the book and what you were
not going to have in the book?
And I will ask you the question
that I asked you earlier on,
which is, I found it interesting
and I wanted to ask you,
one of the biggest, I
think, the most discussed,
at least nowadays,
utopians, Brazilian utopians
and also a failed
utopian, right,
is the idea of racial
democracy and was a tropicalism
that [inaudible] was
writing in the 1930s.
[inaudible] is a
Brazilian sociologist
who wrote [inaudible], I
think is translated as.
Masters and Slaves.
Yeah, that's right.
so, I was wondering, I
imagine the reason is
because it's been discussed
to exhaustion lately, but,
I wanted you to talk a little
bit more about this process
of what going about selecting
what you were going to put
and what you were going
to exclude from the book.
>> Patricia Vieira:
Okay, that's --
it's actually a very good
question and I struggled
with what I was going to
include for a long time.
First of all, to the first half
of the question, of course,
this utopian streak is not
something that is part only
of Brazil, but it's really
part of most American nations,
because the idea was
that Europeans would come
to the new world and this very
concept of the world being new,
of course, it was not new,
there were people here before.
But the conception when the
Europeans arrived with this
that they were arriving
at kind of a blank slate
where they could start
anew and avoid the mistakes
that they had made in Europe.
So, the idea that they could
create a better society
in the New World and
the every publication
of Thomas More's Utopia
is indebted to this idea,
because finally you
had a new world
where you could project all
of these dreams of social,
political and economic
emancipation
that you could no longer think
of in Europe because Europe was
so corrupt and decadent
and so on and so on.
So, the very concept of
a New World is what made
utopia possible.
So, utopia became part of the
makeup of American nations,
much more than it was
of European nations.
And in the case of
Brazil, as you were saying,
I think what struck me is that
even though it's so much a part
of Brazilian history, it hadn't
been studied systemically
and there were a few articles
here and there about utopia
and especially the
utopias in Brazil.
But there was not
a systematic study
of how utopia had
impacted Brazilian thought.
And, so, that was
what I tried to do.
And I selected -- I
didn't want to study books
that were utopias, in the sense
that they presented
alternative visions of reality.
That was not my main goal.
My main goal was really
to study utopian thought
as it presented itself, either
in literature or in books
that were -- books of
sociology, essays and so on
and that had become key to
thinking what Brazil is today.
And, so, I went about
studying this --
and selecting the key moments.
I wanted to key moments
in Brazilian history
that on the one hand
would be representative
of utopian thoughts in Brazil,
so I needed to include
messianism, for instance,
as the root of utopian
thinking in Brazil.
So, the -- like the
theological base
from which posterior
utopia is developed.
So, that was something
I knew had to be there.
And then I tried to
select other moments
that would be representative.
So, I wanted to have one chapter
on the environment as a utopia,
so that was also for sure.
The part on leisure I was
also absolutely sure I wanted
to write about.
Now, the issue of race could
have been another chapter
in the book, but as you
mentioned, it's something
that has been studied a
lot in Brazil, so I thought
that I was not going to be
able to say anything as new
on utopia, on racial democracy
as I could say on other topics.
So, that's why I
kind of bracketed it.
I also didn't mention, as
we were talking before,
I could have written a chapter
on the issue of the reworking
of messanism in the
beginning of the 20th century
with [inaudible]
writing about this issue.
But, again, I decided
against it,
because so much scholarship
has been produced on this
that in the end I
thought I wouldn't be able
to add anything very
substantive to the topic.
But, so, yes, I wanted to
have key moments in utopianism
in Brazil and how it
has changed and evolved,
especially in the 20th century.
So that was the rationale behind
the choice of the chapters.
>> Thayse Lina: One
more thing that I --
after your presentation
I was thinking
about what you just
said and how --
obviously as I was reading
the book I couldn't help
but to think about the moment
that we are going on right now
in Brazil and I was really
glad that you brought it
up in your presentation.
I was surprised and I've
never really thought
about Balsonaro representing
somehow, like,
or I've never really thought
about how he brings back some
of the utopias that you
discussed or representing
or presenting some sort of
utopian view for the Brazilians,
because so much of what
he says is associated
with actually fear and,
right, and he's running
through this fear and that's
how constructed his platform
and his discourse.
But it's certainly
something refreshing.
It made me think
about something else.
What it made me think about
is that most of the times
when you're talking about
utopia we think about --
you're thinking with the
intellectual lead of Brazil
and they dream of what
the country could be
and the confrontation with
the realities of it, right?
That since all of these
actually fall short,
because these utopias are
actually rethinking core
problems of the country, which
are inequality, racial injustice
and so on and so forth.
So, we always feel
like it's falling short
of fixing those problems, right?
But as I was thinking about
it, I was thinking I had
to actually recheck my
position on Balsonato, at least,
not on Balsonato, but on the
people that are voting for him,
because I think in light of
what happened two days ago,
49 million people voted for him.
You ask yourself, what
people are thinking, like,
they really condone these ideas
and are they really
supportive of this.
Or is actually what is moving
them is something else,
it's that they believe
that somehow disregarding
all the violent threats
that is coming from
this candidate,
he somewhat offers a
view of the country
that they actually think
it's important possible.
So, my question, I
think, is it has to do
with this disconnect perhaps
and if you think there
is a disconnection
between what the Brazilian
elites imagine about Brazil --
and I'm sorry I go
back to [inaudible],
because I think it's kind of
like a poignant example of that,
but you can see it in
other ones as well.
I mean, and the idea of
coming together that you see
in Macunaima, the
ideas of community
and the [inaudible]
community, it's also there.
So, if there is a disconnect
between the dreams of the elite
and the dreams of
the people out there,
the ones that we're not studying
or reading or having access to,
but it's more your
opinion about it, I guess.
>> Patricia Vieira: I think --
I think to a certain extent
there is a disconnect,
but I think to a certain extent
also the elites are responding
to something that
is in the country.
Let me make this more concrete.
In the case of the current
elections I don't think there is
so much of a disconnect
between Balsonaro
and the Brazilian
elites and the country.
I think he really
embodies many of the ideas
that have been latent in Brazil
throughout -- for centuries.
Again, the fact that he
presents himself as a savior
of the country, who is
going to bring stability,
peace, prosperity and so on.
This was a discourse, messianic
discourse that has been part
of Brazil for centuries
and is described very well
by [inaudible] in the
Back Lands when he talks
about Antonio [inaudible]
and why people voted for him.
I mean, it's shocking,
but people in many
of the Brazilian slums or
villas, he won, so the people
that are going to
be more impacted
by his policies are
voting for him exactly
because he has been very
clever at appropriating some
of these cultural tropes, some
of these cultural themes are
that are so much part
of Brazilian history
and of the way Brazilians
think about themselves.
And I think this is why
he has been so successful.
And, on the other hand, he has
also capitalized on this feeling
of discontent that is
also, as I was saying,
also comes out of this idea
that you're never able to live
up to the utopian promise
as a Brazilian purpose.
And, so, you're always
falling short
and he has capitalized on this.
He's saying, "I'm
going to overcome this,
we will not fall short
of Brazil's promise,
but we will tackle
these problems
and we will overcome them."
Right? So, I think he has
been a very smart politician.
I don't know if he has done this
more or less without thinking
or if his team of advisors have
really thought this through,
but the fact of the matter is
he has used cultural elements
that have been very
prevalent in Brazilian thought
and he has used them to
his advantage in a way
that I think the left
has been unable to do
and that's why he won.
So, it's not that he's the
candidate of the elites
and the people didn't
vote for him.
No, the people actually
voted for him,
it was not just the
Brazilian elite,
so I think this division
here doesn't apply
because he has really
been selected.
I mean, if anything, there
is a geographic imbalance,
because I think the only
region that did not vote
for him was the northeast
for historical reasons,
Lula being very popular in
the northeast and so on.
>> Thayse Lina: I think
I was thinking more
about the enlightened
midcentury elite and the dreams
of the country coming together
and being more egalitarian.
And that's actually something
that is lacking on
his discourse.
But I appreciate
what you're saying
about how he actually
has conquered the support
of the elites and in some
parts of the population
that would be directly affected
by what he's bringing
to his candidacy.
I don't know if I should -- we
should open to questions now
or if I -- I want to give
people the opportunity
to ask her questions too.
I have a lot of questions.
>> I have a question or two.
[inaudible].
First, thank you for
the presentation.
Is it possible for me --
when you're talking about
this [inaudible], for example,
of the [inaudible] we have in
this [inaudible] of some sort
of utopia, you know,
[inaudible].
First, I have a curiosity
about [inaudible] and the role
that she plays in
this utopian thought
and how do you use her book,
particularly the [inaudible] GH
that we have here in this place,
I would like to hear
your thoughts on it
and how you represent
her in your book.
And another one is I
wonder if in your studies
for this book you
came across this idea
of utopian thought coming
from indigenous [inaudible].
We've heard of how Europeans
sort of rigged this idea
of utopia with them
and then it's reworked
through other moments by
Brazilians themselves, you know,
[inaudible] later on and
the mid-19th century.
But I'm wondering if in your
studies as a [inaudible],
the utopia from [inaudible]?
>> Patricia Vieira: Oh great.
Those are great questions.
So, first about the
utopia from sources
that are not literature
or essays and so on.
Of course, perhaps the most
obvious one would be the
construction of Brasilia in the
1960s as this utopian moment
of creating a space that would
be completely new and modern.
So, again, this attempt
of Brazil to catch
up with the future, right,
and utopia is very --
Brazil is very futuristic in
its architecture as you --
those of you who know it can
probably imagine the center
of Brasilia as this
attempt really
to create the utopian space
concretely, architecturally.
Then [inaudible],
so I read her book
through what I call
interspecies literature,
and this is my new project
I'm working on, literature
and the environment and how
we can think of literature
as a space where we give
voice to non-human beings
and how non-human beings plants,
animals impact literary --
literature and writings
and also cinema.
So, that's how I try to read,
The Passion According to GH,
how the animal in the story
impacts the very writing
of the story.
So, that's through there.
And about the indigenous
cultures,
whether utopia is also part of
Brazilian indigenous thought,
I haven't read too much
anthropological studies,
but there is the concept of the
land without evil in [inaudible]
in indigenous Brazilian
and throughout the Americas
and I forget, I don't
know if any
of you are an anthropologist,
there is even a group
of Brazilian indigenous
peoples who used to go
on a pilgrimage every few
years looking for this land
without evil, so
they would just --
they were settled
in a specific place
and they would just take off
and go look for this land
without evil that
has been compared
to the Christian paradise.
And, so, the idea is presence
in indigenous thought.
I mean, one might
argue that utopia in
and of itself is part
of human culture.
That in one form or another,
it might not be called utopia
because other cultures might
not have a name for this idea,
which western culture did
not have a name for utopia
until Thomas More
published Utopia.
But the idea of something
better than the current state
of affairs is very much a part
of human cultures throughout,
so it would not be surprising
that it exists, you know,
in Native American thoughts and,
of course, in Asian literature,
it's full of utopia --
examples of what we call utopia
in the west, so, yeah.
Any other questions or comments.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> I kind have a question,
but I want to make sure
that if I ask it doesn't
misunderstand your first part
of the lecture.
So, and also I want to
reiterate what you just asked,
but you mentioned
agriculture -- not agriculture,
but environmentalism and the
connection with [inaudible]
and [inaudible] and
this kind of view
that now Amazon is bringing
us this [inaudible].
So, how do we reconcile
the forced labor
that was brought upon
by the rubber movement?
At least in my experience is
studying Peru in the Amazon
and there was what be
[inaudible] genocide
because of the rubber move,
so how does this
utopian narrative kind
of reconcile itself with
finding a better purpose
and better society
when there's --
it's paved the way
by [inaudible]?
>> Patricia Vieira:
Right, right.
Yeah, so, what I was saying
is that this utopian image
of Brazil has been very much
connected with natural resources
that were very abundant
in Brazil.
Of course, no one ever
reflected how those were going
to be extracted, which was
mostly by either slave labor
or later forced labor.
But, so, from a perspective of
the outsiders who were going
to colonize Brazil, this was
one of the main attractions
that you could go to Brazil and
just get wealthy very quickly,
because that country was just
so rich in natural resources,
so that was the utopian
moment there.
In the Amazon, more
specifically, in my chapter
about the Amazon, what I
studied was really the myth
of the amazons, which are --
it's what gave the name Amazon
to the Amazon and these were
just some female warriors
from classical Greece that
when the first colonizers went
to the Amazon they thought
that they saw these women
there along with the river.
So, they gave the name the river
of the Amazons to the Amazon
and that's where
the name comes from.
So, later on, in the
beginning of the 20th century,
this group of women was -- there
are several books of literature
that present this group of
women as a utopian society.
And, so, there are
stories such as, you know,
outsider enters the Amazon,
gets lost, goes to the tribe
of the amazons and realizes
they live a great life
where everyone is equal
and people share the burden
of work and so and so.
They are presented as this
utopian society that contrasts
with the inequalities
of the rest of Brazil.
So, that's the utopian moment.
And, of course, this is located
in the Amazon, because it's
that open space of possibility
where anything can happen
because it's just so huge.
Yeah.
>> How is utopian is the
[inaudible] and shared labor
and that sort of thing,
how do you then [inaudible]
with authoritarian control?
I mean, how was he able
to create this narrative,
is it simply just harkening
back to the good old days or --
because I always thought it
had to have this future goal?
How is this [inaudible]
able to square [inaudible]?
>> Patricia Vieira: Yeah,
no, I think you're right.
There are different strands
of utopianism in Brazil.
So, one of them is this
egalitarian horizontal view
of society that is present,
for instance, in the conception
of laziness and leisure, Brazil
as a country, that is able
to provide for everyone
so people won't have
to work and so and so on.
So, that's one strand.
Now the messianic strands of
utopian, which comes directly
from theology, always has an
authoritarian streak to it.
even if we think about one
of the most famous messianic
real life experiments in Brazil,
which was described, as I
mentioned, by [inaudible]
in the Back Lands, famous
book, which [inaudible] Brazil
where he describes
a community living
in the back lands of Brazil.
The leader of this
community, Antonio [inaudible],
he was what we would call today
really an authoritarian leader
within this community, right?
So, I think that
[inaudible] harks back
to that particular strand of
utopian thought that goes back
to the messianic tradition
and to authoritarianism
within the messianic
tradition, right?
And what I was suggesting is
that I think he has been able
to activate something that has
been part of a Brazilian culture
for a very long time, which
is this thinking of messianism
and the savior that will come
and make everything right.
And this savior often has
authoritarian characteristics.
I mean, historically.
And so people tend to
accept his authoritarianism
because there are other examples
in Brazilian history of this.
And, so, it jus t-- he
falls back onto something
that already exists in the
culture and that's why, I think,
he's so accepted and
so popular really.
>> Maybe we have time
for one more questions?
>> Thayse Lina: I do.
>> Patricia Vieira:
One last time.
>> Thayse Lina: I think that
I was talking to you about it
that -- and I think I'm going
to kind of recuperate some
of your questions
in a certain way.
It was impossible for me to read
a book about utopianism and not
to think -- not about
necessarily negative utopia,
which would be kind of like an
apocalyptical thoughts and --
right, and it would
fall into nihilism.
But mostly about this disconnect
that you see between this dreams
of a better more egalitarian
country, and the reality that --
does these authors were
themselves experiencing
at the time that
they were writing.
And what is interesting is that
not only that I understand that
and you make it very
clear in the introduction
that utopias are not
necessarily to be --
to become a reality or to be,
right, put to work in actuality,
at least not in the intellectual
tradition that you are studying.
They are supposed to work as a
north, right, to be aspired to
and that we are going towards.
But, to recuperating what
people were saying is,
especially if you're looking
at Brazil from the outside,
it always -- it doesn't only
feel like a disconnection
between reality and thoughts
and dreams, but it also seems
that this very reality,
or the dreams
of this more utopian
future are sometimes trying
to fix that reality, right?
Trying to create like another
or to encompass that problem
or that they're seeing there and
to do something else with it.
I think that it becomes
really clear in the utopians
of leisure, which is in a
way a revolt against, right,
or protest against
the imposition
or the necessity of work, right?
So, I wonder if at any point
when you're writing these ideas
were there with you, you know,
thinking about how
there is this contrast?
>> Patricia Vieira: Yeah,
that's a great question
and I think that's the main
criticism against utopia
and the argument that
utopia sometimes leads
to authoritarianism
goes back to that.
That in order to achieve the
utopian goal, anything goes.
So you can do anything
politically
because you have a goal
that you need to achieve.
That was the problem,
for instance,
of communism as a system.
A political system
that -- how is it --
the ends justified
the means, right?
So, when I was studying
utopianism in Brazil I worked
with a different notion
of utopia that I called
in another book I
co-edited a few years ago,
existential utopia.
And, so, by existential
utopia, I mean,
utopia not as a goal
that's somehow hovers above
and beyond society in the
future, but as the utopia
as something that is imbedded
in every day practices, right?
And that's why, for instance,
I think utopia is related
to the environment
are so powerful,
because the environment
is something you encounter
on an everyday basis.
It's not something out there.
And, again, issues of leisure.
People work every day, they
experience labor every day,
so utopias of leisure
are not something
that somehow could
exist in somewhere
in a very distance future, but
they are something that speaks
to our realities in the present.
And I think that's the only way
that a concept, such as the one
of utopia, can still be relevant
today, is if we think about it
as operative on an everyday
basis and not as something
that we should really try to
reach sometime in the future
and that ends up being almost
oppressive in the present.
So, to the country I think
utopias should make us feel
uncomfortable in the
present, but in a good way.
Showing us that the present can
be better, but not as some sort
of an ideal that we always have
to match and we can never match.
But as the kind of
making us slightly --
how I should put this --
slightly uncomfortable
where we sit knowing
that we could be a
bit better, right?
So, I think that's
the kind of utopia
that is valuable
politically today, right,
a utopia that makes us see
that things could be better,
but that doesn't dictate how
they necessarily need to go
and how you necessarily need
for them to be better, right?
>> Thayse Lina: Thank you.
>> Patricia Vieira:
Okay, thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Patricia Vieira: Thank you.